à chaque rentrée depuis 1992 amélie
nothomb ben publie un nouveau roman chez
albin michel
elle a imposé son personnage démontré
que chez elle le sens de la provocation
n'est pas un jean mais une façon d'être
et surtout affirmer ses talents de
romancière amélie nothomb ben raconte un
univers intime le sien avec distance et
fermeté métaphysique des tubes qui vient
de paraître ne déroge en rien à cette
ligne ce sont ces premières années
qu'elle relate ici ce de la naissance à
la petite enfance au japon alors qu'elle
n'est qu'un tube un légume ou mobile un
différend silencieux les parents du tube
était de nationalité belge écrit-elle
donc dieu et des belges ce qui
expliquait pas mal de désastre depuis
l'aube des temps c'est une grand mère
avisé qui éveille l'enfant à la vie en
lui faisant goûter du chocolat car le
plaisir donne la vie
du coup la petite fille entre en
relation avec le monde et ses entretiens
dans japonais avec ses nourrissent son
père lui aussi fasciné par le japon se
mettent à pratiquer noté ap reno
ils vivent dans un pays d'eau l'eau en
moi l'os est témoin écrit amélie nothomb
elle plonge pour éviter la pluie tout
comme les soldats japonais se jetait de
la falaise d'okinawa pour ne pas tomber
aux mains des américains
un livre d'une intelligence remarquable